"You come up here."
We call it that fight mode. Eh, when you're in the middle of a fight you need to have all your adrenaline
on the maximum.
"Shall we try?"
And when you have Wights attacking you from all sides, you're in that super maximum.
To be able to, you've got to loosen up. You've gotta be ready for a fight.
And it needs some screaming. It needs some hitting the axe.
Even the extras are so into it. Ahhh. Oooohh. Ahhhh.
"And she does arrive just in the nick of time. "
"Which is, you just have to. There's no other way that this scene could be written."
One of the main dramatic events of this is of course, the dragons coming to the rescue. And they're north of the wall
and so you get the direct, you know, explosion of fire against ice. Which is the central sort of motif of this
whole story saga.
This is like a cutting torch, you know, going into a piece of ice. Imagine if you dump water into a blazing hot pot, it explodes.
"Rolling and action."
I think back now and there was not a script when I spoke to David and Dan the first time about coming back to the season.
But they told me the story.
And then when they told me, you know, the details of the final scene.
"Alright, everyone ready?"
And this was always the episode that was in some ways we're most excited about and also the most nervous about
because so much of it is dependent on those, you know, that final set piece actually working.
"3,2,1 action"
The eyes of the White Walkers and the Wights have been such a prominent feature of the show and a lot of work
has gone into the specifics of how the eyes look and to see that hopefully iconic image at this point blown up to
the size of, you know, a beach ball. That seems like it was a crowd pleasingly oh shit moment.
Hey everybody.This is my new Game of Thrones Q and A.
But they also dropped this behind the scenes documentary for episode 6 right before I was getting ready to make it
So I just wanted to take some of the best bits of this and talk about it during this video in addition to the Q and A.
So if you are finding me for the first time, we do Game of Thrones every week till Season 8 gets here.
There'll be giveaway stuff at the end of the video.
But don't you just love how crazy Tormund is on set.
The actor that plays him, they're all great people, but the Brotherhood Without Banjos was probably one of the best
parts of all the behind the scenes Game of Thrones stuff this season.
"You need to have all your adrenaline on the maximum."
So it's always cool to see Daenerys flying around and see how they do the dragons from a practical standpoint.
And how they do the wights and these big battles. But really it's when they do these shots like this.
Like just watching the actors try to get down all their sword swings the right way.
But I know when the episode actually dropped it was very divisive for the things that it did not do.
Namely kill one of these big name characters. Like if Jorah had died, that would have been really heartbreaking
in addition to the dragon.
So Dan and Dave talk about how the entire episode turned around this scene here.
So if this hadn't of worked, it would have just been an awful episode, but I feel like for all the dragon stuff, it actually did work out the way they wanted it to.
So all those extra millions poured, literally poured as concrete into this area to make this lake ended up being
worth it.
We can call Tormund explaining fights "Tormund-splaining"
So here we go, first question.
GeeZEvil asked, "Qyburn needs a giant dragonglass arrow for his giant bow."
It's definitely a good idea. I feel like they could benefit from using the giant scorpion in combination with dragonglass.
But there are a number of ways that he could go.
The whole thing about the biggest deaths on the show, like you're talking about Cersei, Night King, Viserion.
I think need to be especially meaningful for the characters that they're most meaningful to.
So I think that the actual heartbreaking truth of it is that Daenerys will be forced to kill Viserion.
She'll be forced to kill her child again.
Think of it as another version of Cersei being faced with a choice to kill Joffrey.
Like she said, "No matter how much of a monster he was, he was still my son."
So Daenerys still thinks of Viserion as her child. When she sees him again with a blue flame it'll break her heart all over again.
Next question.
Michael Ortiz asks, "What if the Night King is the 3rd dragon rider? The dragon has 3 heads."
Yeah there's been a lot of funny jokes about this going around since the season was over.
I do think that that's the closest we'll get to the fulfillment of the prophecy. Unless you believe that Bran can
warg an undead dragon. That's really the crack pot theory that's gaining some steam.
It's like what if Bran could warg the undead dragon and he becomes the 3rd head of the dragon?
"You won't walk again, but you will fly."
Although in reality I think that quote was just about him warging the ravens and than flying around.
Next one.
Kyuketsu asks, "If they hadn't gone through the wall to get proof of the dead and lost a dragon, how would the Night King make it through the wall?"
Well. so this is actually what I think is going to happen in the books and it will involve the Horn of Winter.
Remember after the Night King marked Bran and than it broke the magic seal on the Weirwood.
People were like oh that's very clearly going to brake the magic seal on the wall. That's how they'll get through.
But here's the thing, I feel like Dan and Dave as producers of a television show said that's not cinematic enough.
Them just walking underneath the wall. We need to do something really big and grand. So even though George R. R. Martin told them the ending of
Game of Thrones, it's possible that they embellished the ice dragon part. Bringing the wall down.
I think in the books it will be a little more subtle than that.
And it will have something to do with the Horn of Winter.
Next one.
_sheisdeadjim_. Big Star Trek fan. "Do you think the dragons are going to die or will there be a new dynasty? I mean, would Dany need a new dragon if all her enemies are dead?"
Well, no, she wouldn't need a new dragon but I do think that the two dragons that are still alive will still be alive at the end of the season.
Regardless of what happens to Jon Snow and Daenerys, I feel like there will be new dragon eggs. Like it's meant to be a Dream of Spring,
There's the idea that Daenerys might become pregnant again. She and her family have that deep connection to the dragons, so the idea that things would be born anew.
Spring would come again. So that's just why I think there'll be more dragons in the future of this timeline even if they don't address it directly on the TV show.
Like it depends on if there is a flash forward at the end of the finale episode.
Next one.
Xbitrate asks, "So if Summer is still around, could Bran warg him even if he's turned?"
Well that's actually a big question. It's just like Bran warging a dragon. George R. R. Martin's been asked that for a long time but never said definitively.
I have speculated in the past that Bran's powers will grow as he learns more about them. I think given enough
time he could warg Summer and his powers flow from the Children of the Forest just like the Night King's.
So if their powers come from the same place, than he could probably exert the same level of control over other beings.
But I think the idea is, is that the Night King's consciousness sort of dominates all of the Wights that are risen.
So Bran has to be more powerful than the Night King in order to break his control on someone.
Next one.
MM E asks, "Do you suppose we'll see Daenerys as a Wight?"
She's actually one of the few characters that I don't think is going to be turned into a Wight.
Just because she's so tied to the dragons. I think Jon Snow and Daenerys are probably safe in that respect.
There are a lot of theories about Jon Snow becoming the new Night King.
But it depends on how you feel about the cycle of Ice and Fire. If the whole idea is to break the wheel,
then I think they are trying to make it so there are no more Night Kings.
And that gets into a little bit of book stuff. So, I'm just gonna stick to TV show stuff for now.
When the actual Winds of Winter book drops and we get a bunch more lore for the White Walkers, then we can talk about that a little bit more.
Speaking of which, next one.
Thomas asks, "I was wondering when you think Winds of Winter will be released?"
So this is actually very dangerous to try and predict this. People have done this for the last three years.
I think it will come out next year and than just another year goes by without it happening.
But I do think that it will drop before we get the next season of Game of Thrones.
That would put it firmly late 2018 or anywhere during the middle or early 2019.
But it's been a while since Martin has posted an update chapter.
He used to do that pretty regularly.
He would read chapters out loud when he would go to convention appearances.
But he stopped doing that as much so he could spend more time writing.
So every once in a while, like a couple of times a year we'll get updates.
So I'm expecting another one probably at the end of this year.
Next one.
Kasrose asks, "Predictions for the first episode?"
So I think that most of that episode is gonna be consumed with the reunions at Winterfell.
It'll be a lot of great happy moments.
People are coming from Daenerys' group but the end of the episode will probably be the first big Night King attack.
Remember that the Last Hearth is right up here close to the wall. So R.I.P. Umbers.
They might just tease that at the end of the episode and than use that as the first big action set piece of episode 2.
But that's what I think is going to be the first big Night King attack.
But thank you so much for submitting all of these questions.
These are always a ton of fun to do.
And I'll still keep doing weekly Q and A videos.
There are a lot of other TV shows that are getting ready to come back.
So I might try to do some Q and A videos for those too.
In addition to the Game of Thrones stuff.
But what's gonna happen is I have a Rick and Morty Q and A that'll post tomorrow.
There's a bunch of TV shows that are coming back next week.
So there'll be a couple Game of Thrones videos coming in the next couple of days.
But if you have any special requests just let me know in the comments.
I've gotten a lot of requests for dragon specific videos.
But I'll say congratulations to the latest giveaway winner KilX. Please private message me at the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details. What'll happen is I'll just name a new giveaway winner when I post my next Game of Thrones video.
So if you haven't seen it in awhile you can click here for my episode 6 video for the actual episode.
and you can click here for brand new Rick and Morty.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight.